Traduttore: Valeria Spagnolo
Revisore: Mariagiulia Da Riva
"Stiamo per atterrare,
allacciare le cinture di sicurezza."
Quante volte vi sarà capitato.
Ed è l'unica volta
in cui si ha la possibilità
di vedere dall'alto
la più incredibile, la più potente,
la più diffusa invenzione dell'uomo:
la città.
Ed è anche l'unica volta
in cui, sicuramente,
vi è capitato di pensare,
ma come è possibile che milioni
di persone, da migliaia di anni,
cerchino questi luoghi
per stare insieme, si ammassino,
scelgano di vivere non tutti separati
ma insieme, in quella
che chiamiamo città.
E vi sarà anche passato per la testa
una domanda importante:
Ma è positivo o negativo tutto questo?
Ma sarebbe meglio potenziare
questo fenomeno o limitarlo?
Questa è una storia
che va indietro nel tempo.
In realtà questa è Manchester.
Nel 1845 era la più grande città
e la più popolosa, dell'Occidente.
E come vedete, forse non era granché.
Di fatto in questa città cominciò
quello che io chiamo
il più lungo processo della Storia,
con la sentenza più inaspettata.
E il processo è ovviamente
il processo alle città,
e lo iniziarono questi due ragazzi,
poi diventati abbastanza famosi,
Karl Marx e il suo amico Engels.
Passeggiavano per Manchester
e non vedevano quello che oggi vi capita
quando fate il vostro weekend
a New York o a Parigi.
Immaginate: vedevano
strade strette, senza fogne;
povertà dappertutto;
inquinamento, ma non quello di oggi:
il vero smog, che faceva sì
che delle particelle di carbone
impedissero la vista,
anche l'uno con l'altro.
E ovviamente, i due scrissero un libro
che si chiamava "La condizione
della classe operaia nelle città"
in cui accusavano la città
di tutti i mali del mondo.
Era la città ad essere causa
dell'inquinamento,
della insicurezza, della povertà,
e non c'era altro modo
che limitare questo fenomeno
il più possibile.
Era, come dire, un atteggiamento malsano:
una cosa necessaria, a volte,
ma da contenere.
E da questo, nel corso degli anni
- siamo dal 1850 all'inizio del '900 -
nacquero anche delle discipline
e strumenti per limitare questo fenomeno,
dato che era probabilmente la causa
di tutti i problemi del mondo.
Nacquero delle scienze:
l'urbanistica, che vedete qua dietro.
Una cosa tremenda che forse
avete qualche volta conosciuto,
che ha degli strumenti bizzarri.
Uno si chiama regolamento edilizio,
che è quella roba per cui,
quando dovete cambiare un muro in casa,
dovete fare centinaia di pratiche.
E poi la pianificazione, il piano,
cioè l'idea che ci sia qualcuno dall'alto
che riesce a immaginare
il futuro di una città
nei prossimi 50 anni.
Solo lui, eh, solo nelle sua testa.
O ancora, e per ultima. la zonizzazione,
che fortunatamente
non avete conosciuto tutti,
ma che riesce addirittura a dire,
e a pretendere di immaginare,
in ogni centimetro della città,
cosa debba accadere nel futuro:
qui una casa, qui un ufficio,
qui un teatro.
E poi immaginiamo anche
i film, la cultura,
che si espone molto contro le città.
È famoso un film, una serie
di film, negli anni '80:
Fuga da New York, Fuga da Los Angeles,
dove Manhattan è diventata
un'isola incontrollabile,
una città piena di violenza e di terrore,
tanto da abbandonarla.
E, forse per chi ha visto
il film - vi ricordate?
Diventa un carcere
dove tutti i cattivi del mondo
vengono lanciati dall'alto,
e che si scannino per sempre.
La cosa interessante di questo processo
è che come [in] tutti i processi
- questo forse, anche per l'Italia,
un po' lunghino: dal 1845
a una ventina di anni fa -
arriva la sentenza.
E, caso unico nella scienza,
tale sentenza è una sentenza
di totale assoluzione.
Non solo: leggendo
le motivazioni di questa sentenza,
si scopre che la città non è
la causa di tutti i problemi del mondo,
ma, stante la crescita della popolazione,
essa è la soluzione
a tutte le grandi questioni
cui si affaccia il genere umano:
la demografia; l'inquinamento;
la sostenibilità ambientale;
la sicurezza e lo sviluppo economico;
la creazione di lavoro;
la capacità di creare conoscenza.
Di fatto, questa sentenza elenca
anche tre importanti elementi
che motivano questa capacità,
che la città ha, di migliorare il mondo.
La prima è la densità.
Vedete qua, alle mie spalle,
una mia foto fatta dall'alto
della mia città,
e la densità - cioè quante più persone,
quante più attività,
quante più immaginazioni
riescono a stare
in uno stesso metro quadro,
tanto più questo effetto
positivo si verifica.
La seconda è la diversità,
cioè il fatto che non solo ci siano
tante cose in un posto piccolo,
ma che tali cose siano diverse:
che ci siano poveri e ricchi,
persone di tutti i paesi del mondo,
persone che amano il calcio
o altri che, come me,
ignorano anche il nome
del più famoso calciatore.
Il terzo elemento è la creatività.
Questa è una bizzarra notte bianca
dove migliaia di persone, per una sera,
portano un tavolino,
una sedia da casa, il cibo,
e si riuniscono e mangiano
insieme in una piazza.
La creatività è questa capacità
di immaginare nelle città.
Allora, ecco la mia idea,
che la città, alla fine assolta
e in qualche modo additata come soluzione,
è in realtà un meccanismo.
La definizione di città
non è più la grandezza, gli abitanti:
siamo tutti abituati a confrontare
questa o quell'altra città
per gli abitanti, la grandezza, il PIL.
No!
La città è un meccanismo.
La città funziona e risolve
le grandi questioni dell'umanità
perché è come una scatola nera,
un grande meccanismo
che trasforma interessi diversi,
tanti individui che provengono
da storie, da regioni,
che hanno obiettivi diversi,
che se costretti a fare
un viaggio insieme, in un'auto,
litigherebbero tutto il giorno.
Invece la città riesce
a trasferire magicamente, costantemente,
tali interessi individuali
in benessere collettivo.
E quindi la definizione di città
non è più una definizione statica.
La città salva il mondo
in quanto, costantemente,
riesce a generare questo meccanismo
di trasformazione positiva.
E quindi una città
può anche perdere il suo status.
Adesso sappiamo tutti, alcune città
anche in Italia, anche grandi,
che forse in questo momento,
dopo millenni di storia,
hanno sospeso temporaneamente
questa capacità.
O altre magari neglette,
magari mai considerate
che invece in questo momento,
o per certi periodi,
riescono ad essere
questo meccanismo virtuoso.
E allora non dobbiamo
avere paura della città,
dobbiamo passare da meccanismi e strumenti
di contenimento del fenomeno urbano
a meccanismi e strumenti
che ne accelerino lo sviluppo.
E vi farò due esempi, del lavoro
che sto conducendo in questi ultimi anni
e che non hanno paura del fenomeno urbano
ma che cercano di alimentare
questo meccanismo,
sparandola grossa con utopia e coraggio.
Il primo esempio è di Milano,
e questa è un immagine dall'alto
della città, dal satellite,
e sono evidenziati alcuni parchi,
non tutti, ma un insieme
di verde poco conosciuto,
nel centro della città,
a 10 minuti di metrò dal Duomo,
che insieme, ed è questa la mia idea
- ed è questo anche il viaggio
che ho fatto per anni con questa mappa,
in giro per la città -
l'idea è di nominare
questo insieme di verde con coraggio,
perché si crede nella città,
come il parco urbano più grande del mondo:
72 km di verde,
un parco orbitale che ogni giorno
si può percorrere, come ho fatto.
E che andando, a esempio,
a vedere, le mappe della città,
si può immaginare come elemento
di diversità e di forza,
credendo nelle cose positive
dei sistemi in cui viviamo,
non lasciandoci distruggere
dalla retorica del traffico,
la retorica ancora novecentesca,
prima della sentenza di assoluzione,
delle città come nemici
da repellere, del cemento.
Non so se avete tutti
in mente queste retoriche.
Il secondo esempio è invece
quello di una città
a qualche migliaia di km da qui.
Ci ho lavorato, si chiama Buenos Aires,
in Argentina è la capitale,
e si poneva un quesito, qualche anno fa.
Cosa fare di questa città nel 2030?
Erano tutti spaventati:
Buenos Aires, più che in altri paesi,
è il magnete di tutta la nazione,
il luogo dove tutti
cercano una possibilità.
Ma questo meccanismo,
che è la definizione di città
che vi ho proposto,
si era in qualche modo inceppato.
Violenza, povertà, anche derivata
da una crisi nazionale più ampia.
E la tentazione quale era?
Come al solito, quella
di limitarne lo sviluppo.
E invece con coraggio, sparandola grossa,
con la stessa capacità di credere
nella potenza di questa arma mentale,
quali sono le città,
come col parco orbitale,
anche nel caso di Buenos Aires
ho proposto tre strategie.
Tre strategie che accelerano lo sviluppo,
e che vedete qua dietro:
una maggiore densità,
cioè una maggiore popolazione;
una maggiore infrastrutturazione;
e la creazione di spazi pedonali, o verdi.
Vedete, questa è la densità.
Il piano dice [che] nel 2030
dobbiamo non limitarci, ma aumentare
un milione di abitanti in più nella città,
costruire sostituendo quartieri più bassi
con quartieri più densi,
chiamando la popolazione
non solo dell'Argentina,
ma di tutto il mondo,
e i creativi, a riunirsi.
E poi costruire
un sistema di infrastrutture,
anche su ferro,
che permettano di credere ancora di più
in questo sviluppo, e accelerarlo.
E poi, come vi dicevo,
degli spazi di socialità,
degli spazi di verde e pedonali.
E queste tre strategie, insieme,
scommettevano sullo sviluppo
di Buenos Aires
consci che le città sono la soluzione
a tutti i problemi del mondo.
E allora, quando ancora
una volta atterrerete,
e magari, scegliendo
il posto sul finestrino,
guarderete dall'alto
questa grande invenzione dell'umanità,
che è la città,
avrete nel cuore un sentimento diverso
e saprete rispondere a quella domanda
che vi siete posti tante volte.
E forse, sarete orgogliosi di vivere
in quello che io chiamo
il secolo delle città.
Grazie
(Applausi)